[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Es ist noch ziemlich früh am Morgen.
Man sieht es an den kleinen Augen.
Und heute werde ich ein Frühstück zubereiten.
Da fragen auch immer ganz viele nach den Rezepten.
Deswegen zeige ich euch heute,
wie ich unser traditionelles Frühstück zubereite.
Ich würde es jetzt mal traditionelles türkisches Rezept nennen,
weil es wirklich viele Rezepte
aus der türkischen Kultur beinhaltet.
Aber wir mischen dann auch immer so ein bisschen.
Also dann gibt es auch noch Guacamole dazu
und Hummus und alles Mögliche,
was wir sonntagmorgens einfach gerne essen.
Im Prinzip ist es nicht nur ein Frühstück,
sondern wirklich ein Brunch.
Denn es gibt warme Elemente,
es gibt kalte Elemente,
süß, herzhaft.
Und es wird superlecker!
Ich mache mir kurz eine Liste,
was ich heute alles machen werde,
und dann starten wir direkt.
So chronologisch:
Was bereite ich zuerst vor,
was zuletzt,
damit am Ende die warmen Sachen warm,
die kalten Sachen kalt und das Brot gebacken ist?
[Musik]
Käsedip, darauf warten alle!
Was mache ich noch? Was mache ich noch?
Hm.
>> JOSH: Ui!
>> SALLY: Bei uns explodiert dann immer das Frühstück so.
Okay, ich muss mir Prioritäten setzen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Es sind ein paar Sachen auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Wir fangen an.
[Musik]
Ich backe ja ganz gerne Brot selber.
Heute mache ich ein schnelles Pfannenbrot.
Da gibt es das Rezept auch schon auf meinem Kanal.
Das geht wirklich schnell.
Was aber auch superschnell geht,
ist zum Beispiel magisches Baguette.
Da bereite ich den Teig auch gerne mal am Abend vorher zu
und kann ihn dann einfach im Kühlschrank aufgehen lassen,
abgedeckt, und am Morgen einfach die Brötchen aufbacken.
Jetzt, wie gesagt, das schnelle Pfannenbrot.
Dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach
alle Zutaten in die Küchenmaschine.
Der Teig muss ja
oder darf gerne auch ein bisschen aufgehen,
muss er aber nicht.
Und dann kann ich hier
in der Zwischenzeit alles andere vorbereiten.
Und ich habe jetzt hier
nicht wie im Originalrezept, was ich euch verlinken werde,
nur Weißmehl benutzt,
sondern auch einfach halb/halb mit Vollkornmehl gemischt.
So hat man einfach direkt so ein bisschen
auch ein dunkleres Brot.
[Musik]
Während der Knetzeit jetzt nicht trödeln,
sondern am besten direkt alles weiter vorbereiten.
Was bei einem Frühstück in der Türkei nie fehlen darf,
sind Kartoffeln.
Die werden halt frittiert
und morgens gibt es dann halt schon Pommes zum Frühstück.
Aber ich muss echt sagen, das ist immer so eine coole
gesunde und ungesunde Mischung aus allem.
Von daher darf man sich auch morgens mal Pommes gönnen.
Die habe ich jetzt geschält.
Die werden kurz abgewaschen
und dann schneide ich sie direkt.
[Musik]
Die Kartoffeln übergieße ich jetzt mit ein bisschen Wasser,
damit sie nicht braun werden.
Und die werde ich dann einfach später frittieren,
damit sie eben auch schön warm sind,
wenn wir uns zum Frühstück setzen.
[Musik]
Der Teig ist mittlerweile perfekt.
Den decke ich jetzt ab
und kann ihn aufgehen lassen.
Damit es bei mir aber schneller geht,
nehme ich jetzt die Gärstufe im Backofen.
Da muss er nämlich nur eine halbe Stunde aufgehen,
ansonsten einfach eine Stunde,
wenn man jetzt keinen Dampfbackofen hat.
[Musik]
Jetzt bereite ich die Eierspeise vor,
also Menemen.
Da gibt es auch schon ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal.
Es ist ein bisschen älter,
ist noch aus der alten Wohnung,
aber es ist trotzdem gut.
Das bereite ich jetzt hier vor.
Dafür werde ich jetzt nämlich
Zwiebeln schälen und fein schneiden.
Dann diese kleinen grünen
oder die langen grünen Spitzpaprika,
– die gibt es meist beim Türken –
die werden mit angebraten.
Tomaten kommen rein.
Und ganz am Ende kommt dann das Ei dazu.
Und das ist auch echt superlecker
und das essen wir auch total gerne.
Und da kann ich jetzt alle Komponenten vorbereiten,
einfach schon mal schneiden.
Und so bereite ich mir immer alles schön vor
und dann kommt man eigentlich auch nicht in Stress
und nicht in Zeitverzug.
[Musik]
Normalerweise gibt es beim türkischen Frühstück
immer auch noch Pişi dazu.
Das ist wie Lángos.
Aber ich glaube, das mache ich heute nicht.
Ich glaube, das wird zu heftig.
Vielleicht mache ich noch türkischen French Toast dazu,
also in Ei ausgebackene
– höhö, die Stimme...
Also in Ei aus-
– höhö.
Wo ist denn meine Gesangsstimme hin?
Also in Ei ausgebackenes Brot.
So. Jetzt habe ich es.
[Musik]
Sarah ist nicht da. Jetzt muss ich alleine.
Wuh!
[Musik]
I used to think maybe you love me.
Now, baby, I'm sure!
And I just can't wait 'til the day
when you knock on my door!
Now every time I go for the mailbox,
gotta hold myself down!
>> FREDERIC: Nein, nein.
Nein. Einfach nein.
>> SALLY: 'Cause I just can't wait
'til you write me you're coming around!
I used to think maybe you love me.
Now I know that's true!
And I don't wanna spend my whole life
just awaiting for you!
>> FREDERIC: Meghan Trainor?
>> SALLY: Now I don't want you back for a weekend,
not back for a day!
>> FREDERIC: Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier tun soll.
>> SALLY: Baby, I just want you back
and I want you to stay!
Oh, yeah! Now I'm walking on sunshine!
Whoa!
Was für eine schräge Stimme!
Sarah, wo bist du, wenn man dich braucht?!
Mein Gott!
Mein Gott! Wo ist diese Frau, wenn man sie braucht?!
Jetzt geht sie Joghurt kaufen
und lässt mich mit dieser schweren Stimmlage allein!
Den Song haben meine Zuschauer ausgesucht.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist sehr süß.
>> SALLY: For you!
>> FREDERIC: Danke fürs Aussuchen.
Scurr, scurr.
>> SALLY: Guten Morgen. Ich mache gerade Frühstück.
Okay, der Sturmi ist schon da.
Ich kann kein Pişi mehr machen.
Die Kartoffeln habe ich.
Das Brot habe ich.
Rührei habe ich.
Sucuk und Ei, ja.
Ich bereite jetzt erst mal Gemüse vor
und dann Käse- und Wurstplatte.
Und die Aufstriche habe ich auch schon,
also hier.
Und Hummus und Guacamole habe ich auch schon.
[Musik]
Jetzt gibt es viel Gemüse.
Also traditionell immer Gurken und Tomaten,
dann lege ich dazu noch Oliven,
kleine Paprika.
Meine Frühstücksgäste sind schon da.
Magst du mir helfen?
So macht man das.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: Man bereitet so lange vor,
bis der Gast mithelfen muss.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist die Tradition?
>> SALLY: Das ist so die Tradition.
Tradition.
Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Nicht?
>> SALLY: Ich habe kein Karohemd an.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt mache ich das.
Kein Stress,
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: ich übernehme das.
Ich kümmere mich später darum.
>> FREDERIC: Sind das Jalapeños?
>> SALLY: Nein, das sind nur Minisnackgurken.
>> FREDERIC: Ah!
Oh?
>> SALLY: Äh,
Paprika.
>> FREDERIC: Ist alles okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Es ist alles okay.
>> FREDERIC: Hier.
>> SALLY: Kannst du hier drauf machen.
>> FREDERIC: Hallo?
>> JOSH: Ah ja, noch nicht.
>> SALLY: Oh, stimmt. Du hast noch kein Mikrofon.
>> FREDERIC: Ich klaue mir mal eins.
>> JOSH: Ja, der hat sich einfach so reingeschlichen.
>> SALLY: Der hat sich einfach so reingeschlichen, nicht?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich klaue mir da eins.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ja, mach das.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Also hier noch die Snackpaprika drauf.
Teewasser habe ich schon aufgesetzt.
Tee mache ich gleich.
>> FREDERIC: Schneiden? Nicht schneiden?
>> SALLY: Nee, die legen wir so drauf.
Und dann zeige ich dir jetzt was.
Ich glaube, das kennst du nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Noch nicht.
>> SALLY: Also jetzt gibt es noch Tahin Pekmez.
Tahin ist Sesampaste.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und Pekmez, das ist so eine Melasse
aus Trauben.
Ups!
>> FREDERIC: Also süß eher?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und das wird dann gemischt.
>> FREDERIC: Traubensirup.
>> SALLY: Und dann gibt es das so als Dip dazu,
so als Brotdip, Aufstrich.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so, ich dachte...
Aber nicht hierfür?
>> SALLY: Nee, nicht hierfür.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und das macht man,
weil das auch supernahrhaft ist.
Und dann gibt man das auch immer Kindern,
die vielleicht so ein bisschen zu wenig essen,
dass sie einfach so ein bisschen...
>> FREDERIC: Mehr essen.
>> SALLY: Nicht Specki kriegen,
aber das ist auch appetitanregend und...
>> FREDERIC: Das ist super für mich!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Habe ich mir auch gedacht.
>> FREDERIC: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Guck. Und dann einfach Traubenmelasse.
Zack!
Und da steht zwar Traubensirup drauf,
aber es ist kein Sirup, es ist Melasse.
Das ist so der Rest, was übrig bleibt,
wenn der Zucker irgendwie aus den Trauben entzogen wird.
>> FREDERIC: Aber Sirup hört sich dann besser an,
wenn man höchstwahrscheinlich im Supermarkt steht.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Aber die meisten denken bei Sirup direkt
an Zucker und so weiter
und eigentlich ist es das nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Kein Zucker?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> FREDERIC: Mh.
>> SALLY: Das ist halt wirklich so aus den Trauben heraus.
Möchtest du das mal so versuchen zu verrühren?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, klar.
Perfecto.
>> SALLY: Die Sesampaste, die
ist halt immer nie so ganz homogen,
weil keine Emulgatoren drin sind
und dann setzt sich immer das Fett ab.
Dann fülle ich schon mal Marmeladen um.
Denn das Auge ist ja mit.
>> FREDERIC: Das stimmt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Alles, was fertig ist, packe ich mal da rüber.
>> FREDERIC: Und das machst du jeden Morgen?
>> SALLY: Nein.
Nur sonntags.
>> FREDERIC: Nur sonntags?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Wir kommen Sonntag noch mal wieder.
>> SALLY: So zur Feier des Tages.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Heute gibt es auch Melone.
Also eigentlich gibt es beim türkischen Frühstück
echt immer viel Obst und Gemüse.
>> FREDERIC: Sehr gesund, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und wenn man sich dann mal so
die Kartoffeln anguckt,
da gibt es...
>> SALLY: Die werden gleich noch frittiert.
>> FREDERIC: Die gibt es...
Ach so. Ach, also es gibt wirklich Kartoffeln?
Ich dachte jetzt, die Almans...
>> SALLY: Ach so!
>> FREDERIC: Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ich wollte nicht frittiert werden heute Morgen.
Wenn wir dann so mit unserem Brötchen und Käse kommen
und dann so...
>> SALLY: Okay, gut.
Bei uns gibt es das auch.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Man kann ja so
von allem etwas.
>> FREDERIC: Du, ich finde das gut.
>> SALLY: Wenn man es nicht jeden Tag macht,
ist es doch okay.
>> FREDERIC: Wenn man die Zeit hat dafür,
das jeden Tag zu machen, ist es aber auch gut.
Dann sagt mal Bescheid, Instagram oder so.
Ich würde schon vorbeikommen für das Frühstück jeden Tag.
>> SALLY: Dann ist es schon gut.
>> FREDERIC: So. Ich habe das jetzt gemacht.
Ich probiere hier weiterhin,
alles aus dem Schneebesen rauszuklopfen.
>> SALLY: Ah, perfekt.
Dann kannst du es
>> FREDERIC: Ist das für dich...
>> SALLY: vielleicht in so zwei Dinger rein machen.
>> FREDERIC: Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es aussehen soll.
Ich lerne.
>> SALLY: Ja, das sollte...
>> FREDERIC: Ich werde hier noch angelernt.
>> SALLY: Es sollte schon schön, angenehm,
appetitlich,
flüssig.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: So. Brotteig ist fertig.
>> FREDERIC: Brotteig?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Oh!
>> SALLY: Ich backe noch Brot.
>> FREDERIC: Selber?
>> SALLY: Aber wir sind gleich fertig.
Wir sind gleich fertig.
>> FREDERIC: War ich zu früh?
Das tut mir sehr leid.
>> SALLY: Etwas. Ich habe eigentlich damit gerechnet,
dass du wie immer zu spät kommst.
>> FREDERIC: He, he, he, he, he!
Wir hatten keine festen Uhrzeiten ausgemacht.
>> SALLY: Immer so halb zehn, zehn.
Und dann warst du heute halt so krass...
>> FREDERIC: Also ich würde es einfach so und jetzt ein Brot.
Nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und heute warst du so krass pünktlich.
>> FREDERIC: Ich war immer um halb zehn hier.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> FREDERIC: Ich meine natürlich 7:30 Uhr.
Das ist ein Job! Ja.
So.
Also ich glaube, das hatte den gegenteiligen Effekt.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen,
aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass es den gegenteiligen Effekt hatte.
>> SALLY: Wir nehmen einfach noch ein bisschen Melasse.
Das ist flüssig.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Komm schon!
Einen Job hatte ich bis jetzt!
Einen einzigen Job!
>> SALLY: Okay. Das ist auch fertig.
Da gebe ich noch Früchte drauf.
[Musik]
Ich habe nur hier schon Hummus und Guacamole gemacht.
>> FREDERIC: Guacamole gehört dazu?
>> SALLY: Nee, das mache ich dazu.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen.
>> SALLY: Das ist so Sally.
[Musik]
Besser, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Ich glaube, jetzt ist es okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann gibt es jetzt türkischen Tee.
Ich zeige dir, wie man den...
>> FREDERIC: Lege ich das hier drauf?
>> SALLY: Nein, einfach ins Waschbecken.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das machen wir gleich weg.
Den magst du, gell? Den Tee.
>> FREDERIC: Den?
>> SALLY: Den hast du schon getrunken.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich mag generell also eure Tees,
deine Tees hier die ganze Zeit.
>> SALLY: So.
>> FREDERIC: Ich finde das sehr gut.
>> SALLY: Und der wird einmal ausgewaschen.
Und nach dem Auswaschen
dann aufbrühen mit heißem Wasser.
Und dann einfach ziehen lassen
so etwa 15 Minuten.
Und dann hat man hier oben das Teekonzentrat drin
und hier unten das kochende Wasser
und dann kann man immer bestimmen,
wie stark der Tee sein soll.
Und außerdem bleibt der Tee schön warm
und wird nicht bitter,
weil nicht das hier gekocht wird,
sondern das Wasser da unten.
Deswegen macht man das so.
>> FREDERIC: Gut.
Guck, geholfen.
>> SALLY: Super!
Dann kannst du das
>> FREDERIC: Was sagst du dazu?
>> SALLY: auch da nach – ups!
Sehr gut.
Nach links stellen.
Dann haben wir das auch fertig.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hier ist Hummus.
>> SALLY: Das ist auch fertig.
>> FREDERIC: Soll ich den rüberstellen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oh ja, Oliven.
Guck mal, die kannst du auch noch anrichten.
>> FREDERIC: Hast du die selber eingelegt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: In?
>> SALLY: In Olivenöl,
in Orangenschale,
Knoblauch,
und Rosmarin.
>> FREDERIC: Da startet man den Tag richtig jetzt, oder?
>> SALLY: Start your day right.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt können wir schon mal die Kartoffeln frittieren
und das Menemen, also das Rührei, machen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich nehme ganz kurz.
Di-di-dip.
Für dich. Du nimmst jetzt auch.
>> FREDERIC: Das Ganze höchstwahrscheinlich, oder?
>> SALLY: Na, schon ein bisschen. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Schon ein bisschen?
>> SALLY: Schon, schon...
Da rein so.
>> FREDERIC: Die erst oder möchtest du erst Öl?
>> SALLY: Erst Öl. Dann erhitzen wir erst das Öl.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und...
Ja, das reicht.
Wir müssen es nicht übertreiben.
Und dann werden die einfach da drin frittiert,
so wie man das halt jeden morgen macht.
>> FREDERIC: Brutzeln vor sich hin so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich kann jetzt hier die Zwiebeln anbraten
mit den Spitzpaprika.
Die sind nicht scharf.
Isst du eigentlich scharf?
>> FREDERIC: Sehr gerne. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay, dann machen wir Chili drauf.
>> FREDERIC: Mmh!
Jetzt müssen sie alle leiden.
>> SALLY: Jetzt müssen sie alle leiden.
[Musik]
Ja, geht schon.
>> FREDERIC: Wenn du da jetzt deinen Finger
reingehalten hättest,
dann hätte ich wirklich mir Sorgen gemacht langsam.
Ah, der redet schon.
Hallo!
>> SALLY: Der redet.
>> FREDERIC: Alle?
>> SALLY: Mh, wir gucken mal wie viel.
Ich glaube, wir machen halbe-halbe.
Mh.
Ein bisschen noch.
Ja,
halbe-halbe.
Da machen wir auch einen Deckel drauf.
So.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann
– oh, dann können wir noch einen Käsedip machen.
Das ist so der Lieblingsdip von Samira und Ela.
Und den lieben auch die Zuschauer.
Die wollen immer wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Jetzt darfst du den gleich machen.
Ich hole kurz den Käse.
>> FREDERIC: Das mache ich natürlich geschwind.
Ist ja einfach.
>> SALLY: Also hier hast du jetzt ein Päckchen Sahne,
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: 200 Gramm.
Und da nehmen wir jetzt ein Rädchen Käse.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so, das sind verschiedene Rädchen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ah, okay. Irre!
Nehme ich.
>> SALLY: Und den nimmst du
und zerkleinerst du jetzt einfach in...
>> FREDERIC: Einfach zerkleinern?
>> SALLY: In die Sahne rein. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Boah, der fühlt sich ja voll crazy an!
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist Weichkäse.
Wir lieben den.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
So?
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> FREDERIC: So.
>> MURAT: Aha!
>> FREDERIC: Moin, Chef!
>> MURAT: Ich gehe in den Shop.
>> SALLY: Hä? Wir frühstücken doch jetzt.
>> MURAT: Ja, ihr seid leider zu langsam.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Ich gehe in den Shop nach Mannheim.
Macht's gut!
Tschüss! Bis später.
>> FREDERIC: Bis später!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> FREDERIC: Ich komm gleich auch in den Shop.
>> SALLY: Ich dachte, du bleibst bei uns zum Frühstück.
>> MURAT: Nein, keine Zeit.
>> FREDERIC: So, so.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Hm.
Denen geht es gut.
>> FREDERIC: Hm. Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann wird das hier...
>> FREDERIC: Erhitzt.
>> SALLY: Jetzt komme ich so an die Grenzen
meiner
Platzmöglichkeiten.
Hier gebe ich jetzt noch die Paprika dazu.
Und die wird jetzt einfach auch mitgeschmort.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, wir wandern hierüber
mit dem Käsedip.
>> FREDERIC: Ich bewundere gerade einfach nur.
Ich stehe hier sehr...
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> FREDERIC: Hallo, ich bin ein Zuschauer.
>> SALLY: So.
Und dann hole ich den Schneebesen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann darfst du den Käse rühren.
Und der schmilzt jetzt hier drin.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Yes, yes.
>> SALLY: So.
>> FREDERIC: Aber das wird ja noch nicht
das ganze Geheimnis des Käsedips sein, oder?
>> SALLY: Nein, nein, nein.
Da kommt dann noch Mehl dazu
zum Binden.
>> FREDERIC: Ich rühre das hier so lange,
bis es schöner Käse wird.
Boah, das sieht so lecker aus und riecht so gut alles!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Dann nehme ich hier noch einen Tulum-Käse.
Den musst du auch probieren.
Der ist der Wahnsinn!
Das ist so ein ganz traditioneller Käse,
so würzig.
>> FREDERIC: Das sind richtig viele Käsis aber, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, so feinstückig.
>> FREDERIC: Der wirkt schon so
fast ein bisschen parmesanartig, oder?
>> SALLY: Hm, so ein bisschen hartkäsemäßig. Ja.
Der wurde im Fass gereift
und deswegen ist der so ganz besonders aromatisch.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und, weil du Chili magst, gebe ich noch Chili drauf.
>> FREDERIC: Da habe ich mir was eingebrockt jetzt. Oje!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hm, hm, hm.
>> FREDERIC: Ich rühre hier fleißig.
>> SALLY: Sieht gut aus.
Das kocht gleich.
Dann löst sich alles.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Boah!
Das, boah!
>> SALLY: Kennst du das? Menemen?
>> FREDERIC: Nee, auch nicht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Das ist lecker.
>> FREDERIC: Ich merke das schon.
Wenn wir hier mit dem Frühstück durch sind,
sind wir beide erst mal so: "Uff, ah!
>> SALLY: So richtig satt.
>> FREDERIC: Lecker!
Lecker!"
>> SALLY: So richtig mittagsschlafsatt.
>> FREDERIC: Mittagsschlaf. Ja.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Mittagsschlaffrühstück.
Das ist was, da isst du, bist fit
und dann legst du dich noch mal hin.
>> SALLY: So, etwas Honig.
Oh, komm. Bei mir muss auch Erdnussbutter sein.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Bei dir?
>> FREDERIC: Gerne auch mal. Ja.
Aber nur mit so Marmelade oder Honig dazu, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja!
Mit Marmelade.
>> FREDERIC: So wie Peanut Butter Jelly.
>> SALLY: Oh yes!
>> FREDERIC: Hm, hm.
>> SALLY: So. So langsam gehen die Schälchen aus.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Also ich hätte bei mir in der Küche fünf Schüsseln.
Ich glaube, da wären wir schon lange drüber, oder?
>> SALLY: Da sind wir drüber.
>> FREDERIC: Da sind wir drüber.
Machst du das mit einem anderen Ei auf?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Und warum geht das andere Ei nicht kaputt?
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, weil immer eins härter ist
als das andere.
>> FREDERIC: Und da hast du das geschulte Auge dann für,
meinst du?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Da suchst du dir immer
das harte Ei aus aus sechs?
>> SALLY: Stimmt, es geht immer das kaputt,
was ich in der rechten Hand habe.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wahrscheinlich weil ich das draufschlage.
>> FREDERIC: Nee, ich glaube, du machst das immer
mit der...
Also du machst das nicht bewusst?
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte.
Okay. Warte. Ich mache es nicht bewusst.
Ich probiere es noch mal.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Du nimmst das. Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Und du schlägst es immer mit der...
>> SALLY: Ah!
Siehst du? Immer
– Achtung! –
das, was ich draufschlage, geht kaputt.
>> FREDERIC: Ha!
Es ist aber mal tatsächlich mal ganz interessant,
da mal rauszufinden, warum das andere nicht knackt dann,
oder?
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte. Dann versuche ich es mal.
Also, wenn man...
>> FREDERIC: Das ist hier für mich wie Zauberei,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Wenn man das eine draufschlägt,
das, was man schlägt, das geht kaputt.
>> FREDERIC: Wie im Leben.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wow!
>> FREDERIC: Kleine Weisheit am Morgen.
>> SALLY: Das sind echt voll die Weisheiten hier.
>> FREDERIC: So. Das köchelt.
>> SALLY: Köchelt? Okay.
Dann...
>> FREDERIC: Ich rühre um. Dann verbrennt es nicht.
>> SALLY: Warte, warte, warte.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also das ist ja der Käsedip, den alle so lieben.
Käse und Sahne gekocht,
der Käse hat sich aufgelöst
und dann bindet man das Ganze einfach mit Mehl.
Das heißt Koşapka.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das ist ein Rezept von meiner Freundin.
Die ist Çerkes.
Tscherkessin heißt das, glaube ich, auf Deutsch.
Das ist so eine bestimmte Region,
so eine bestimmte Gruppe.
Und das ist ein ganz traditionelles Rezept dort.
>> FREDERIC: Käsedip?
>> SALLY: Hm, so ein warmer Käsedip.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das ist echt...
>> FREDERIC: Wie ist Kino bei denen in der Region?
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> FREDERIC: Lecker.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, wahrscheinlich, oder?
Wenn das schon so ein traditionelles Gericht ist,
ist das megageil dann.
>> SALLY: Okay,
die Paprika habe ich leicht anbrennen lassen.
Aber das macht nichts.
>> FREDERIC: Röstaromen.
>> SALLY: Röstaromen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hier kommen die Tomaten dazu,
werden mitgeschmort,
bis sie weich sind.
>> FREDERIC: Perfekt.
>> SALLY: Dann haben wir das auch.
Und ich sollte so langsam...
Das sieht gut aus, nicht?
Zeig mal.
Ja.
Die Konsistenz ist perfekt.
Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Einmal.
Bis zur Hälfte so?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Soll ich dir einen Teigschaber holen?
>> FREDERIC: Yes. Gerne.
So.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Käsedip ist auch fertig.
>> FREDERIC: Es ist schwierig, das alles zuzubereiten
am Morgen, – oder? –
wenn man selber noch so ein bisschen Quwee hat.
>> SALLY: Ja, also ich
mache das, wenn wir halt drüben so privat sind.
Dann machen wir so
– manchmal machen wir ein paar Storys dazu.
Und dann lasse ich Musik laufen.
Und dann...
Geht eigentlich.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, also ich glaube, wenn man...
>> SALLY: Also ich meditiere da so vor mich hin morgens.
>> FREDERIC: Das glaube ich.
Sollen wir noch Schnittlauch irgendwo reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Oh!
Oh, Schnittlauch!
Den habe ich am Abend so schön geschnitten.
Den habt ihr nicht live erlebt.
Das war so eine Schubkarre voll Schnittlauch.
>> FREDERIC: Wir waren ein paar Stündchen zu spät.
>> SALLY: Ihr wart leider zu spät.
>> FREDERIC: Sonst hätte ich natürlich mit geschnittlaucht.
>> SALLY: Natürlich.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt bin ich gespannt, du.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt machen wir die schön gleich groß.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann Pizza?
>> SALLY: Und dann
rollen wir die.
So.
Guck. Und jetzt immer so einen Teig nehmen.
>> FREDERIC: Mache ich mit?
Ich mache mit.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Da weiß ich nicht, ob das gut ist.
>> SALLY: Und so von außen nach innen.
>> FREDERIC: Ich bin ehrlich. Wegen dem Pflaster
habe ich eigentlich ein bisschen Sorge hier.
Ich gucke dir zu.
Ich kommentiere das mit frechen Kommentaren.
Echt? Das nennst du einen Ball?
Wow!
Das ist die Technik?
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist die Technik.
Ich kann es auch einhändig. Hier.
So von außen nach innen.
>> FREDERIC: Also, wenn ich damit jetzt anfange,
bist du fertig und dann wirst du meinen korrigieren.
Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen.
>> SALLY: Guck, so.
Und dann hast du auch einen Ball.
>> FREDERIC: Und das werden dann so Brötchen?
>> SALLY: Und das werden so flache Pfannenbrote.
>> FREDERIC: Pfannenbrote?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Das ist schon
– das ist cool.
So wie Naan-Brot, nur ein bisschen fluffiger.
>> FREDERIC: Oh, Naan-Brot, lecker!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist ein bisschen so,
als wenn du so Hütchenspieler wärst manchmal.
So und dann so: "Na, wo ist das Brot drunter?"
So dl-d-d-d-d-d.
>> SALLY: Und so zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann auf einmal
kommt so eine Gurke raus und alle nur so: "Hä?"
>> SALLY: Genial! Stimmt.
>> FREDERIC: Ah, das kann man abschrauben an der Seite?
>> SALLY: Ja. Und dann kannst du das draufmachen.
>> FREDERIC: Das wusste ich natürlich.
>> SALLY: Habe ich dir den geschickt?
>> FREDERIC: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Aber gut, sonst
– da wäre ich, glaube ich, nicht drauf gekommen.
Das wäre jetzt unangenehm gewesen.
Das wäre wieder ein klassischer
Freddie-liest-Gebrauchsanweisungen-nicht-Moment gewesen
von: "Ah, guck mal! Das kann man so rollen. Wie cool!
Warum sind die Dinger da drin?"
>> SALLY: Die sind nur Deko.
>> FREDERIC: Ah! Damit man...
Ah! Immer die gleiche Größe wegen dem Abstand.
Ah!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Okay. Ja, verstehe ich.
>> SALLY: Aber ich glaube, ich mache sie tatsächlich dünner.
[Musik]
So.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Jetzt aber.
>> FREDERIC: Und die kommen dann auf ein Blechlein.
Oder?
>> SALLY: Die backen wir gleich in der Pfanne.
>> FREDERIC: In der Pfanne?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Wir können in der Pfanne backen?
>> SALLY: Ja,
Pfannenbrot.
>> FREDERIC: Du bist aber auch kreativ
mit deinen Backwegen hier.
>> SALLY: So wie Naan-Brot.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, die haben doch immer diesen...
>> SALLY: Ja, die haben so ein...
>> FREDERIC: Ich wollte gerade sagen Tunnel,
aber das wäre jetzt auch falsch.
Das ist ja immer dieses Loch,
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
>> FREDERIC: wo dann Holz drin ist.
Und dann pappen die das an die Seite.
>> SALLY: Oh, das hätte ich ja so gern!
>> FREDERIC: Das können wir machen.
Also das kann ich dir bauen.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> FREDERIC: Nein.
Ich wollte nur cool sein.
Aber das können wir rausschneiden,
die Stelle, wo ich gesagt habe, ich kann das bauen.
>> SALLY: O Mann!
>> FREDERIC: Also das kriegen wir doch bestimmt hin.
>> SALLY: Ich hätte es so gern! Da gibt es nämlich ein...
>> FREDERIC: Du kannst das bestimmt bauen, nicht?
Ja, ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Da gibt es so ein richtig gutes
türkisches Hauptgericht.
Das nennt sich
[Trommelwirbel]
Testi Kebab.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Tasty Kebab.
>> FREDERIC: Tasty Kebab. Ja, okay.
Ich kann mir grob vorstellen, was es ist.
Nicht 100 Prozent, aber...
>> SALLY: Und das ist in so einem Tontopf
und es wird in die Erde in so ein Feuerloch
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: gelassen und dann darf das da halt garen
so einige Stunden.
Und dann machst du diesen Tontopf außenrum kaputt
und perfekt.
>> FREDERIC: Aha!
>> SALLY: Das ist richtig, richtig genial!
Aber dafür brauche ich halt so einen Tontopf,
den man zerschlagen kann.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, und vor allem so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen Außenfläche für so ein paar Sachen.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, das ist...
>> FREDERIC: Was ich ganz geil finden würde,
wäre so ein eigener Pizzaofen, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: So ein Stein-Holzkohle-
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
>> FREDERIC: Holzkohle-Ding einfach mal schnell.
Das kriegen wir doch bestimmt
schnell zusammengebaut, oder?
>> SALLY: Kannst du das bauen?
>> FREDERIC: Ha!
Ich kann es probieren.
Aber das ist dann immer mit der Prämisse
– wenn ich das hier baue, ist das immer mit der Prämisse:
>> SALLY: Es gehört auch dir.
>> FREDERIC: Es ist mit Comedy gemacht worden.
>> SALLY: Okay, guck mal. Menemen ist so weit.
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Das ist mir zu heiß.
>> FREDERIC: Noch mal. Das ist zu heiß?
>> SALLY: Ich nehme mir die mal.
>> FREDERIC: Dann kann ich ja höchstwahrscheinlich
mich nicht mal annähern dem Topf.
>> SALLY: Ich nehme die mal kurz aus dem Bild,
die Kartoffeln,
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: und mache uns hier Platz.
Also eigentlich geht das mit den Kartoffeln echt schneller,
aber die Kartoffeln, die waren
seltsam.
Na ja...
>> FREDERIC: Die wollen heute nicht.
>> SALLY: Die wollen nicht.
Gut. Jetzt habt ihr hier diese Masse.
Die wird jetzt gewürzt
mit Salz und Pfeffer.
>> FREDERIC: Scht!
>> SALLY: Die Kartoffeln, die wollen in den Mittelpunkt.
Dann Oregano.
Nee! Bergbohnenkraut.
>> FREDERIC: Wird das dann gemörsert,
das Bergbohnenkraut, wenn es so...
>> SALLY: Ja, ich zerkleinere das so ein bisschen.
>> FREDERIC: Mit der Hand?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Deswegen nennt man sie auch im Fachkreis
den Mörser natürlich, nicht?
Das ist immer hier,
Salz und Pfeffer, bevor das da reinkommt,
>> SALLY: Salz, Pfeffer mache ich...
>> FREDERIC: wurde immer noch einmal
durch die Hände gemörsert.
>> SALLY: Einmal durchgemörsert.
>> FREDERIC: Sie braucht eine Nebenbeschäftigung.
Da steht sie hier, mörsert alles weg.
>> SALLY: Danke.
Riecht schon gut.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Bergbohnenkraut, das ist schon...
>> FREDERIC: Da mörsert sie wieder.
Da mörsert sie wieder!
Da sieht man es mal wieder.
Der Mörser vom Neckar.
>> SALLY: So. Probier mal.
>> FREDERIC: Wenn du Rapper wirst, ich sage es dir.
>> SALLY: Ich bin der Mörser vom Neckar.
Probier mal. Vorsicht, heiß!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, gut, das heißt bei mir...
>> SALLY: Vorsicht, sehr heiß!
Geschmacklich aber gut, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Geschmacklich sehr lecker. Ja.
100 Prozent.
100 Prozent sehr lecker.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und jetzt fülle ich die hierein.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das ist jetzt so optisch mehr.
Also ich hätte es auch darin garen können,
aber die sind mir zu klein jetzt für
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: zwei Portionen.
Und jetzt gebe ich das hierein
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: und das hier.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann mit so einem Brot so.
>> SALLY: Hm.
So mit dem halbflüssigen Ei.
>> FREDERIC: Hm. Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm, hm, hm.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Ich mag die Sprache, die hier gesprochen wird.
Auf, Essen!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
Boah!
>> SALLY: Das muss aber ganz kurz warten,
damit wir hier schon mal das Brot jetzt backen können.
Und dann haben wir es gleich.
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Und dann nur noch Sucuk und Ei.
Sucuk und Ei heißt:
Sucuk in Pfännchen braten,
Ei dazu, fertig.
>> FREDERIC: Cool!
>> SALLY: Hier riecht es nach Ei.
>> FREDERIC: Welches riechst du davon?
>> SALLY: Nein, aber
irgendwo auf der Arbeitsplatte.
Nicht Ei in der Schüssel, sondern Ei auf der Arbeitsplatte.
Riechst du das?
Hier riecht es nach Ei. Ich sage es euch.
>> FREDERIC: Hier riecht es...
Aber ganz ehrlich, bei so zwölf Eiern
könnte ich mir schon gut vorstellen,
dass das tatsächlich irgendwo ein Ei ist.
Ich glaube, ich mache das mal,
wenn du bei mir vorbeikommst.
Da werde ich einfach mal irgendwo
so ein bisschen Ei verteilen im Büro
und dann werde ich mal gucken, ob sie auslöst
oder ob das alles nur eine große Show ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann mitten im Büro:
"Das ist ja sehr schön.
Ei!"
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich...
>> FREDERIC: Das ist aber ganz gut, oder?
Machst du das auch an Schlüssel oder so,
wenn du den mal verlierst?
So einmal kurz noch mal so in ein Ei gedippt.
>> SALLY: Ja, dann rieche ich dran.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann immer so: "Da!"
>> SALLY: Weißt du aber, was auch oft das Problem ist?
Wenn du was mit Ei gemacht hast
und dann so gewaschen hast und gespült
und dann machst du das Fenster...
Das klingt echt weird.
Dann machst du das Fenster auf...
>> FREDERIC: Ich bin bereit jetzt. Ja. Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann machst du das Fenster auf
und wenn die kalte Luft reinzieht,
dann stinkt es noch schlimmer nach Ei.
Deswegen lass immer die Fenster zu.
>> FREDERIC: Man merke,
heute mal können wir hier einblenden
– kriegen wir ein Overlay hin?
Sallys Tipp: Niemals kalte Luft auf Eigeruch!
Dann wird es mehr.
>> SALLY: Aber...
>> FREDERIC: Ich freue mich auf das nächste Buch,
wenn das irgendwo drinsteht bitte.
Und weil ihr hier viel mit Ei gearbeitet habt...
>> SALLY: Aber es ist wirklich so!
Und wenn du zum Beispiel einen Kuchen machst mit Baiser,
ja, mit Ei obendrauf,
und du stellst den raus zum Kühlen,
dann stinkt der nach Ei.
Wieso veräppelt er mich?
Es ist so!
>> FREDERIC: Ist gut.
Nächstes Mal, wenn ich vorbeikomme,
machen wir mal Baiser oder so
und dann machen wir mal den großen Test.
>> SALLY: Och menno!
>> FREDERIC: Das hast du nicht im Bild,
wenn man so ein Baiserstückchen im Garten verteilt.
>> SALLY: Ja, ist so!
Ist echt so!
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Jetzt backen wir mal die Brote.
Die sind ohne Ei.
Da ist ein Ei drin.
>> FREDERIC: Da ist ein Ei drin?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Guck mal an. Und dann haben wir es ja gleich.
>> FREDERIC: Und das machst du ohne Öl,
ohne irgendwas da rein?
>> SALLY: Ohne Öl.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann ist das fertig?
>> SALLY: Und dann ist es fertig.
Das ist schon cool.
Die Kids machen da voll gern mit morgens.
Die rollen dann immer aus.
>> FREDERIC: Das glaube ich.
Das ist eine gute Beschäftigung.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Dann haben sie schon mal was erlebt am Morgen.
So.
Sucuk und Ei kennst du?
>> FREDERIC: Ist das Sucuk und dann Ei,
Rührei damit gemacht?
Oder...
>> SALLY: Ja, so als Spiegelei.
>> FREDERIC: Als Spiegelei?
Als Spiegelei hatte ich es noch nicht.
Ich hatte das nur immer mal so in so ein Rührei so einge-
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> FREDERIC: Eingeschnitten dann aber auch nur,
mit kleineren Stückchen.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Sehr lecker.
Lauchzwiebeln oder so dazu, das ist dann ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Oder Schnittlauch.
>> FREDERIC: Schnitti.
Oh!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Es riecht halt immer wie die Hölle.
>> FREDERIC: Sollen wir das Fenster zulassen dann?
>> SALLY: Ja,
damit das Ei nicht stinkt.
Wir übertönen jetzt den Eiergeruch mit Sucuk.
>> FREDERIC: Das finde ich gut.
Boah, die kleinen Schälchen! Nicht?
10 von 10 einfach.
>> SALLY: Süß, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Mega!
>> SALLY: Dann kann man da echt so voll schön...
>> FREDERIC: Und dass du das direkt darin machen kannst,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: ist halt geil.
>> SALLY: Einfach drin anrichten und dann ist es echt schön.
>> FREDERIC: Du sparst dir ja einen kompletten Schritt,
nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Einen kompletten Schritt mit Waschen.
Einfach so keine Pfanne mehr.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Einfach hier drin und darin servieren.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: So. Reicht das für uns zwei dann?
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: So an Frühstück?
Oder vermisst du noch was?
>> FREDERIC: Also weiß ich nicht.
Ich hätte noch eine Pizza gerne.
Nee. Ich glaube
– also ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist,
aber ich esse ja sehr reichlich am Morgen.
Also ich arbeite mich auch gerne
von Hummus zur Guacamole einfach mal durch
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: durch das Alphabet.
Das ist schon ein alphabetisches Frühstück, nicht?
>> SALLY: Es ist schon so.
>> FREDERIC: Das wäre mal ein gutes Video.
>> SALLY: Von A bis Z!
>> FREDERIC: Hm, ein Frühstück von A bis Z.
Und dann machst du immer Sachen von A
>> SALLY: So nennen wir das Video.
>> FREDERIC: wie
>> SALLY: A wie Apfel. B wie Banane.
>> FREDERIC: Apfel, Banane...
>> SALLY: C wie
>> FREDERIC: Cerealien
>> SALLY: Cerealwa...
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: D wie
>> FREDERIC: Deftiges Ei.
>> SALLY: Dip.
>> FREDERIC: Oder Dips. Ja.
E wie...
>> SALLY: E wie
Ei.
>> FREDERIC: E wie Ei. Ja.
>> SALLY: F wie Feigen.
G wie Guacamole.
>> FREDERIC: Kann man schon machen.
Es ist schon das A-bis-Z-Frühstück.
>> SALLY: H wie Hummus.
I wie
>> FREDERIC: Igitt, noch mal Ei.
>> SALLY: Igitt, Eiergestank!
Ja, es ist schon
– doch, es klingt gut.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, ich mache das jetzt so.
>> SALLY: Und dann machen wir das Ei rein.
Denn
es sieht immer schön aus,
wenn die Sucuks dann so da obendrauf liegen.
>> FREDERIC: Aha!
Okay.
>> SALLY: So.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Eins.
>> SALLY: Çay.
Aufstriche.
Hummus.
Wurstplatte streiche ich raus.
Das war es.
[Musik]
Bei Şakşuka kommt kein Ei rein,
aber bei dem kommt Ei rein.
Da gibt es einen Song.
Shakshuka,
shaka da shuka.
Shaka da shuka,
Ich habe den Songtext vergessen.
Okay. Komm, wir richten an.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oje!
[Musik]
Hier beim Menemen noch ein bisschen Salz und Pfeffer.
Und dann dürft ihr es so ganz leicht verrühren.
Und da darf das Ei aber gleich
schon ein bisschen noch weich sein.
So mögen wir es gerne.
Es zieht auch gleich ein bisschen nach.
[Musik]
Sturmi, komm!
>> FREDERIC: Hui!
>> SALLY: Ach, der Sturmi ist ja zu Besuch
und ich habe mir gedacht:
"Komm, bauen wir ein kleines Frühstück auf."
Und eigentlich habe ich mir gedacht,
so schön
für uns
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: was Kleines,
>> SALLY: Sonnenwetter.
Und statt Sonnenwetter haben wir jetzt
leider Baustellengeräusche, Regenwetter.
>> JOSH: Warte, warte, warte!
Das kriegen wir hin.
>> SALLY: Was?
Ah!
>> FREDERIC: Wie?
>> SALLY: Sturmi, jetzt können wir uns aussuchen,
wo wir hinwollen!
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Wir gehen jetzt...
>> FREDERIC: Können wir zum Mond?
>> SALLY: Wir fliegen, ja, zum Mond.
>> FREDERIC: Was müssen wir machen? Schnipsen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oder nach Venedig.
Oh, ich war noch nie in Venedig.
[Vogelgezwitscher]
Oder...
Oh, auf der Bosporus-Brücke in Istanbul.
[Musik]
Hörst du das? Hörst du die Musik?
Oder...
>> FREDERIC: Das ist ein Vogel, oder?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Oder – wo wollen wir noch hin?
>> FREDERIC: Moment. Können wir neben so einen Löwen?
>> SALLY: Einen Löwen?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Frisst der uns nicht alles weg?
>> FREDERIC: Weiß ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, wir probieren.
>> FREDERIC: Wenn der sehr nah dran ist, müssen wir,
glaube ich, sehr still sitzen bleiben aber.
>> SALLY: Okay, probier es.
[Löwengebrüll]
>> FREDERIC: Nicht bewegen! Nicht bewegen!
Ein Nilpferd.
>> SALLY: Im Dschungel!
>> FREDERIC: Im Dschungel.
[Dschungelgeräusche]
Und jetzt wohin?
>> SALLY: In Paris.
[Musik]
Non. Non, rien de rien.
Non!
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Da müssen wir ganz schnell wieder weg.
>> FREDERIC: Barcelona.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: In Frankfurt.
Wer will schon nach Frankfurt, wenn er in Waghäusel ist?
>> FREDERIC: Wo stehst du denn davor?
Dann ist so Commerzbank-Zentrale, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Berliner Mauer.
>> FREDERIC: Berliner Mauer.
Ich klatsche jetzt.
>> SALLY: Können wir auch in deine Küche?
>> FREDERIC: Aber nur ganz kurz,
weil es ist, glaube ich, nicht aufgeräumt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, weiter geht es.
Wieder in deine Küche.
>> SALLY: Yay!
>> FREDERIC: Das macht gar keinen Sinn.
Wir sind ja schon hier.
>> SALLY: Hawaii.
>> FREDERIC: Hawaii?
>> FREDERIC: Da bleiben wir jetzt?
>> SALLY: Da bleiben wir jetzt. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir essen?
Wir haben noch gar keine Teller.
>> FREDERIC: Ach, das macht man doch, nimmt man...
>> SALLY: Nee.
Tatsache, eigentlich nimmst du dir so ein Brot.
>> FREDERIC: Nimmt man immer ein Brot und...
Hm.
>> SALLY: Hier.
>> FREDERIC: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: So. Und dann probierst du dich so durch.
Also
>> FREDERIC: So der mobile Teller.
>> SALLY: Käsedip.
>> FREDERIC: Oh ja, den muss ich direkt mal probieren.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Der ist leider kalt, denn wir sind zu viel gereist.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Aber lecker.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Mmh!
Hm.
>> SALLY: Menemen, schön würzig.
>> FREDERIC: Boah! Das wird richtig gut schmecken,
glaube ich.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: Könnte man in das
– wie heißt das? Menemen?
Könnte man da auch noch Sucuk reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Definitiv.
>> FREDERIC: Das würde, glaube ich, ganz gut schmecken.
>> SALLY: Murat liebt Menemen mit Sucuk.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mh.
Dann
Sucuk.
>> FREDERIC: Sucuk, ganz klar.
>> SALLY: Also das ist echt so.
Als wir früher mit meinen Eltern in der Türkei waren
bei unserer Familie,
da gab es dann alles so,
am Boden aber
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: mit so einer acht Meter langen Tischdecke.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Alles wird am Boden ausgelegt.
Dann nimmst du dir die Tischdecke auf den Schoß,
weil du sitzt ja am Boden
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: auf den Knien.
Und dann ist die Tischdecke praktisch
deine Serviette zum Schutz.
>> FREDERIC: Hm!
>> SALLY: Und dann isst man so am Boden.
>> FREDERIC: Da werden also oft Tischdecken gewaschen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Boah, so lecker alles!
>> JOSH: Der Hintergrund wird langsam schwer.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Ach komm, dann geh aus dem Hintergrund raus.
>> FREDERIC: Dann machen wir doch
– was war es?
Waghäusel, nicht?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Dann machen wir doch wieder Waghäusel.
>> JOSH: Schnipp!
>> SALLY: Oh, hier ist es aber auch schön!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, es ist schon schön.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Oder? Also ich finde es ganz gut.
Und auch alles so frisch hier im Hintergrund.
Da können wir uns noch was holen nachher.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich habe Brombeeren.
>> FREDERIC: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Oh! Probier mal Tahin.
>> FREDERIC: Oh ja! Das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Weil du hast gesagt, das ist ein Aufschnitt
– Aufstrich,
>> SALLY: Aufstrich. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: der gesund ist,
>> SALLY: Ja, mit Sesampaste...
>> FREDERIC: aber auch süß.
>> SALLY: Sesampaste und Traubenmelasse.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Habe ich gerührt.
Sonst liegt es an mir.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Hm?
>> FREDERIC: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Der ist gesund?
>> SALLY: Aber sehr nahrhaft.
Also es hat schon viele Kalorien, aber gute Kalorien.
>> FREDERIC: Verdammt noch mal!
>> SALLY: Gutes Fett, gute Kohlenhydrate,
>> FREDERIC: Irgendwann kommt der Mittelwert.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Eisen. Deswegen gibt man es gerne Kindern
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: oder stillenden Frauen,
>> FREDERIC: Hammer!
>> SALLY: dass die Milch gut wird.
>> FREDERIC: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Hast du doch!
Ja, ihr tragt immer Milchpakete dann.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Hm, über die Schulter geworfen so. Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann isst man alles so durcheinander.
Und das ist so lecker!
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Oh! Und jetzt tu mir noch einen Gefallen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mh.
Probier den Tulum.
>> FREDERIC: Auch damit?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Chili hast du extra reingemacht, nicht?
>> SALLY: Extra mit Chili.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Ich probiere mal zu greifen.
Hm, hm, hm.
Okay, Chili. Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
>> FREDERIC: Schmeckt gar nicht so aufdringlich.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Also der schmeckt
– traditionell in der Türkei schmeckt er sehr
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: stark,
>> SALLY: weil er in so Fell gemacht wird.
Aber hier wird er einfach in Fässern gereift.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Deswegen schmeckt er würzig,
aber nicht so dominant.
>> FREDERIC: Weißt du, von wem das kommt?
Das kommt von mir,
jemandem, der nicht gerne Käse isst.
>> SALLY: Ja,
ich nämlich auch nicht.
Also eigentlich so milden Käse mag ich,
aber so Stinkekäse mag ich nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Also...
>> FREDERIC: Vielen Dank fürs Frühstück,
sage ich nur, nicht?
>> SALLY: Bitte schön.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist echt der absolute Oberhammer!
>> SALLY: Das machen wir jeden Tag.
>> FREDERIC: Du willst wirklich nicht, dass ich gehe, nicht?
Wie das aussieht hier.
>> SALLY: Ich will nicht, dass er geht.
Ich will nicht, dass er geht.
Deswegen habe ich ihm Frühstück aufgetischt.
Ich habe es mit Kuchen und Torten versucht.
Ich habe es mit Pizza versucht.
Ich habe es mit allem versucht.
Aber er geht trotzdem!
>> FREDERIC: Ich komme aber wieder.
>> SALLY: #sturmimussbleiben
>> FREDERIC: Eine Petition, eine Online-Petition...
>> SALLY: Wir machen eine Online-Petition.
Stalkt ihn und schreibt drunter:
>> FREDERIC: He! He! He! He!
>> SALLY: "Sturmi muss bleiben!"
So.
Also das war unser kleines Frühstückchen.
Morgens halb zehn in Deutschland.
>> FREDERIC: Aber lecker!
>> SALLY: Aber sehr lecker!
Okay, zugegeben, das gibt es nicht jeden Tag.
Das gibt es echt so sonntags.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Unter der Woche essen wir echt gern
Müsli, Porridge, gesunde Sachen, Smoothies.
Und so was gibt es dann
ganz ausführlich und reichlich am Wochenende.
Da sitzt man dann zusammen
so drei Stunden und isst und schnackt und ja...
Die Rezepte gibt es natürlich online auf sallys-blog.de
oder in der App.
Und ich freue mich jetzt auf eure Frühstücksbilder,
auf euer Frühstücksbüffet.
>> FREDERIC: Dito.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Tschüssi!
>> FREDERIC: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir noch mal verreisen so zum Abschluss?
>> FREDERIC: Wohin?
>> SALLY: Turkish Airlines bitte!
[Stewardessenansage]
>> FREDERIC: Köln.
>> SALLY: Köln.
[Kirchenglocken]
Dubai.
Da war ich noch nie.
[Autohupe]
>> FREDERIC: Mh.
Tschechien.
Sliwowitz-Brauerei.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Nein, Quatsch.
Nein, nein, nein.
>> SALLY: Oder, oh, oh,
auf einen Berg!
>> FREDERIC: Auf einen Berg?
>> SALLY: Wir sitzen jetzt auf einem Berg.
>> FREDERIC: Vielleicht finden wir da Bergrübenkraut.
Heißt das Rübenkraut?
>> SALLY: Bergbohnenkraut.
>> FREDERIC: Bohnenkraut.
>> SALLY: Da vorne wächst es!
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da vorne.
>> FREDERIC: Ah, da! Komm, lass uns was mitnehmen.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir laufen mal runter.
>> FREDERIC: Da können wir jetzt noch
hier so einen schönen Wanderweg.
>> SALLY: Ja. Oh! Und einmal an den Nordpol.
>> FREDERIC: Einmal an den Nordpol?
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und jetzt!
>> FREDERIC: Nee, ist nicht so gut. Es ist kalt.
Mag ich nicht.
Können wir an den Südpol?
>> SALLY: Südpol?
Da ist es auch kalt.
>> FREDERIC: Da ist es das Gleiche, nicht?
Da haben wir wieder nicht aufgepasst in Erdkunde.
>> SALLY: Okay, komm. Wir chillen jetzt am Strand.
Tschau!
>> FREDERIC: Tschüss!
Ecuador.
>> SALLY: Hat jemand Sonnencreme für mich?
>> FREDERIC: Ich hätte ein Brot.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
Wollt ihr jetzt eigentlich auch dazu frühstücken?
Oder sollen wir alles alleine essen?
>> AYLIN: Wie ihr wollt.
>> FREDERIC: Wie? Das ist für die?
>> SALLY: Lässt du noch was übrig für die anderen?
>> FREDERIC: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Njam, njam, njam, njam!
>> FREDERIC: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Kommt! Teamfrühstück!
[Musik]